i want you to remember the number line
we've seen the number line before here's
a number line
missing some things though what could i
put onto this to make it a little more
complete uh yeah jaren would you reckon
no numbers would be good to put on
number line what's the most important
number
on the number line zero it's zero very
good now i could i can put zero wherever
i like
what a nice sensible place is to put it
in the middle very good
so i'm going to put it where is my
center i've got an even number so i'm
going to put it there
okay that's fine now we we as a
convention we say okay going to the
right our numbers get
bigger larger okay so i'll go one two
three
four i've chosen one two three and four
i could have chosen like
5 10 15 20 10 20 whatever i like song is
that consistent
if they're getting bigger this way that
means they're getting smaller
that way so i'm gonna go yeah negative
one
negative two negative three so here's
our integer language coming in right
lovely
but yesterday you noticed right that
when you want to like represent
something
in space okay we live like if you want
to draw a map
okay this which is one dimensional maybe
you want to write that down
this is one dimensional
there's only one direction you can go
back and forth in okay kind of doesn't
cut it it's kind of not enough
right so what if we wanted
what if we added um
a dimension so that we have something
which is two dimensional well you can
see here's a number line over here
and all i need to do to add an extra
direction there is to say well he's left
right
that's right let's have up down okay so
i'm going to put a line
straight through so now i've got two
number lines right
each number line represents a dimension
so now i've got something
which is two-dimensional
this is two-dimensional now just like
before right
i still got all my numbers here in fact
let's let's mark them in i've still got
zero
right there in the middle i've got one
two three
going this way i've got negative one
negative two negative three
going this way but now i have this extra
number line hanging around
and i want to be able to describe where
i am on that one as well
so it needs numbers too so
just like i've got left to right let's
put some markings here
now just like before we said okay let's
make this direction
get bigger the positive direction and
let's make this direction get smaller
the negative direction which would you
like me to make positive when which one
negative which you think makes sense
yeah let's go negative down and positive
up
um you don't have to define it that way
but if we're on the same system that
will make sense
i already have zero in there right at
the middle going climbing up
one two and three climbing down
negative one negative two negative three
okay now when you have a look at this
we've now introduced a whole new massive
uh really fun idea okay
this is not a number line anymore it's
got two dimensions it takes up 2d space
so we call it
another plane so
the heading is number plane
number plane has two dimensions as you
can see over there
it's what happens when you put two
number lines together and they're um
they're perpendicular they're at right
angles
so when you got two of them we give them
special
names do you notice the way i've drawn
it it's quite
symmetrical do you see that there's like
the right-hand side of the left-hand
side to get the same
you got the top bottom half exactly the
same think back
think back to geometry when you've got a
shape and it's exactly the same on both
sides
we say it has what kind of symmetry
because it's more than one kind of
symmetry does it remember
we oh interestingly i can rotate this
around but if i've got like say
my face right which is i over here over
here here over here
here etc what do we call that reflection
yeah good i can reflect
across we didn't say rotational before
okay so
when you've got something which has
reflectional symmetry or
this way as well what do we call that
middle light has a special name starts
with an a
we call it an axis of symmetry
so i have an axis up here right this up
down one
it's an axis but i also have this one
going across
it's also an axis okay
so because i've got two axes axis is the
plural by the way
you might want to dot that
axes is the um what did i just say
oh plural that's right what am i good of
axis yeah it is spelt exactly the same
as like axes like is in like throwing
axes but
it's axes okay i've got two axes over
here i want to be able to distinguish
between them so we give them names yeah
christian
okay so we call them the x
axis and the y axis
they're our axes we name them in this
order alphabetically
because we usually start with this
horizontal one right so
x comes first in the alphabet and then
we're like oh let's add on this extra
idea an extra dimension an extra
axis up this way and y comes after so
this one first
then that one okay now just like before
we want to be able to describe places
like on a map okay
if we have to do one at a time
you mean like an a axis and a b axis is
that what you're talking about yeah
so you know we're calling them x and y
um sometimes you'll have different
things that these numbers are referring
to
like they might be time or temperature
or kilometers or any other quantities
you want to
compare this is a really huge idea it
goes all over the place so you
call them anything you like but let's
just try and get some common language
first so
x is usually the number we have like an
unknown so that's what i'm starting with
x
all right so we've got axes on our
number plane
another important thing is if i want to
be able to describe a place
like say hey that spot over there
right like that's on a map how would you
describe that right
so let's get here for a second we use
just like with the maps you looked at
yesterday
we use coordinates
and you should um you should underline
that phrase
coordinates i'll talk about it in a
second to describe places
or points
on the plane
whoops there we go okay by the way we do
mean plane as in like a flat surface as
opposed to flame like
i'm on a plane okay so we use
coordinates
to describe these points okay and you
can see
if you've got a number for how far
across you are
an x number and if you've got a number
for how up and down
you are that's a y number then that's
all the numbers you need you just need
two numbers and that'll describe you
everywhere and that's why they're called
coordinates right when you see the word
ordinance ordinance it really just means
like a value
okay like we say ordinal sort of
values ordinal data it means something
which has a number on it
when you see the word co on the front of
a word like
cooperate or co-interior or
can someone give me some more examples
someone give me another yeah leaders
okay yeah
okay all right co-pilots
okay what does that mean what does that
mean
it usually means two but importantly two
that are together yeah if you're
cooperating right you're working
together if you've got coordinates
you've got values that are
put together together okay so
coordinates always come in pairs as we
will mention thank you questions
yes yes co-linear means together
on uh what do you think linear means
linear linearly together on a line right
so for example
uh these guys here they're all co
linear right and there's all kinds of
things that are similar okay
so i just need two numbers and here's
the way we write
our coordinates so you can write them up
here with this guy right from this wrong
color
because we try and keep things
alphabetical so we don't get confused
okay
we'll give an x number first and then a
y number we'll keep that available right
so this guy what's the x number that
matches up to that point
one plus one isn't it in fact you may
like to draw some little dots there so
you can see it goes down to one
so i've got a one and then i'm like okay
now give me the y
number so i'll put a comma what's the
one number that fits yeah
two two very good so i can see that just
there
one comma two and i've got these round
brackets here they're actually called
parentheses that indicate
hey this isn't just a random pair of
numbers they're coordinates
they tell me where to go okay now
remember i asked you before which is the
most important number on the number line
which is it
zero zero right it's this guy here okay
so what do you think is the most
important set of coordinates on the
number
plane zero zero very good
so maybe you want to draw an arrow in
there because probably if yours
is like mine the center of your plane is
quite busy
so draw an arrow up there this is zero
zero right you need two numbers one to
tell you don't go left or right
and the other one to go don't go up or
down just stay there it's so important
we give it a whole
special name we call it
the origin it's where everything starts
you know if you're counting this way or
that way or this way or that way
you start counting you start from the
origin
and then you go okay all right so now on
the same axis right
let's see if we get this idea you could
tell me
this point where it is i'm going to tell
you
some coordinates and i want you to tell
me where i should draw the dots
how about this
pause for a minute don't shout it out i
want you to think
how would you describe verbally how to
get
to this spot beth what do you reckon
along the x axis to negative three
okay so i'm going one two three over to
the left good yep
then up um on the y axis on one
here yeah like that what do we think yes
thumbs up cool and you can see you might
like to draw in again these dots here
okay i'm there i'm there negative three
one awesome okay can you remind me again
how did i know
to go negative three to the left and not
negative three down why not why not do
that one
first why not aaron yeah i'm doing
things
alphabetically okay alphabetically so
you do x first
then you do one okay